hi folks
we're here today to talk about
transitioning to modern javascript in
order
to get better value and performance out
of every bite
i'm hussein and i'm jason hussein are
you ready
uh ready for what ready to play is it
modern the show where i quiz contestants
on whether a piece of javascript is
modern or not modern hussein you're our
lucky contestant today
let's begin for question one we have
these two lines of code what do you
think hussein modern or not modern
hmm i i see months is declared using var
and i'm pretty sure index ob was
introduced in es5
so this is not modern correct
there's no inherently new syntax being
used here so it's not modern onto
question two
another two lines of code is this modern
along the same lines
object.assign isn't a relatively new
syntax or anything so
again i'm going to go with not modern
you're right
not modern alright last question this
piece of code is a little larger and i
promise it's not a trick question
what do you think modern or not modern
taking a look here i don't think there's
anything modern
regarding the promise syntax but i do
see a variable being declared with const
and constantly wasn't introduced until
much later so
this has to be modern code ooh tricky
block scoped lead and const are actually
supported in internet explorer 11.
there's a few bugs to keep in mind but
we can run this code
wow okay i guess i learned something new
today
um are you really going to be doing this
the whole time jason
no but that kind of begs the question
what exactly do we mean when we say
modern code
well for starters modern javascript is
not es 2015 syntax
or es 2017 or even es 2020
it's code written syntax that is
supported in all modern browsers
right now chrome edge firefox and safari
make up ninety percent of the browser
market and then another five percent of
usage
comes from browsers based on the same
rendering engines
which support roughly the same features
that means 95 of visitors to your site
are using a fast modern browser
the browsers that make up majority
market share are also
evergreen which means that they get new
javascript features over time
but how do we write or generate code for
a moving target
the easiest way is to look to the
features that are already widely
supported first up classes which have
over
95 browser support arrow functions
96 generators also have 96
browser support probably the most
underused javascript feature
in particular this six line generator
implements a lazy binary search over the
dom
yeah to be honest i can't think of ever
having to write a generator
by hand this might have been my first
block scoped constant let declarations
save us from var hoisting issues and
have 95
browser support and like we mentioned
earlier this is actually partially
supported
in some older browsers so if we're
careful we could almost call this 97
support destructuring has 94
support rest parameters and raise spread
also
94 object shorthand which was easy to
forget
that this wasn't in the language before
es 2015
now has 95 browser support and finally
async await
which even though is an es2017 feature
has 95 browser support this is
easily my favorite feature of the
language oh really not uh not generators
we're using the term browser support
quite often and it's worth clarifying
what that means
you can think of browser support as the
percentage of global web traffic from
browsers
that support a given feature to get a
full picture of modern javascript
browser support
we can take the lowest common
denominator of the features we just saw
and we can see that all these features
are supported in 94
of browser traffic now keep in mind this
is even higher
for newer sites and apps as an example
the total here would be 97
for visitors only from the us
yeah so while it's actually pretty
useful to have a rough idea of the
browser support for language features
you're going to use
most of us aren't writing code that gets
delivered totally unmodified to run in
browsers
we rely pretty heavily on transpilation
say i wanted to have a function that
returns promises resolving to the number
42
i might write a little async arrow
function like this one in order to have
that code run
in the last five percent of browsers
that don't support async arrow functions
i might transpile it to something like
this
or at least i might try in reality most
current tools are going to take my 21
bytes source code and transpile it to
something like 583 bytes of source code
plus a runtime library that the
generated code depends on which actually
brings us up another six and a half
kilobytes to 7000 bytes
obviously the transpiled code will take
longer to load than the original version
it's larger but the dramatically larger
compiled code also
runs significantly slower once
downloaded
javascript code gets compiled to
instructions that are executed by a
virtual machine
and we can count those to estimate how
much work is required to run a given
program
so our original async function compiles
to 62 instructions
whereas the transpiled output compiles
to over 1100
we can also benchmark these side by side
and the transpiled version executes more
than six times slower
and this size increase is actually
relatively consistent across
modern features pulling all of those
earlier syntax examples into a single
module
is about 780 bytes when minified using
terser to remove white space
if we then transpile that the generated
code is six kilobytes
that's seven times more and the only
benefit we got was that it could run in
internet explorer 11 if we add another
10 kilobytes of polyfills that it
depends on
theoretically we also support opera
mini's extreme rendering mode
although in reality most transpiled apps
still won't work in that mode because of
other limitations
now we know that the code in the left
here works in 95
of browsers and a lot of us are already
writing modern code like this
so it's tempting to say well that's fine
i'll just ship that modern code that i
wrote
to browsers well you can think that you
can change all the code in your
application but if we actually take a
step back
and look at what makes up our website
code we'll find that the majority of our
code base
comes from third-party dependencies data
from http archive shows
that half of all websites ship almost
ninety percent
more third-party code than first party
right so i did some really rough napkin
calculations which is always dangerous
uh but working back from global web
traffic we can estimate that the
overhead of shipping legacy javascript
accounts for around
80 petabytes per month of internet
bandwidth
that extra bandwidth shipping
unnecessarily polyfilled and transpiled
code
produces something like 54 000 metric
tons of carbon dioxide into the
atmosphere
we'd have to plant 30 million trees to
offset that much carbon dioxide
these are obviously super approximate
numbers but they kind of help paint a
picture of the scale of the problem
yeah and a big part of that scale comes
from how prevalent this issue is on npm
if we take a look at the top thousand
front end modules on the npm registry
the median syntax version is es5 the
average
is also es5 in fact less than 25
contain any syntax newer than es5
only eleven percent of modules use the
browser field and ninety percent of
these points
to es5 two percent of modules have a js
next main field
and all but one are es5 and only nine
percent of modules use
the module field so why is this
a big part of the reason is that package
authors can't rely on application
bundlers to transpile dependencies to
ensure browser support we estimate that
only
half of build tools transpile
dependencies at all
which means that modern code published
to npm gets bundled as is by the
remaining tools and that unexpectedly
breaks browser support for those users
thing is package authors came by this
honestly as modern javascript got
popular packages still published in es5
because it could be hand
tuned where general purpose transpilers
have to be spec compliant so they don't
break valid code
package authors could transpile to more
efficient output by making assumptions
specific to their source
maybe i'm using classes but i only use
the bits that transpile to simple
functions and prototypal inheritance
as we found ourselves using more and
more modern javascript syntax over time
those possibilities for lossy
transpilation faded away
thankfully this is now a solvable
problem historically
npm packages declared a main field
pointing to some common js code
which as we know is generally assumed to
be es5
recently node and a number of bundlers
have standardized a new field called
exports it's great does a lot of things
but it has one very important attribute
which is that it's ignored by older
versions of node
this means that modules referenced by
the exports field
imply a node version of at least 12.8
and node 12.8 supports es2019
that means that we have to assume
modules referenced by the exports field
are modern javascript going forward
there's at least two types of npm
packages i expect to see
we have modern only where there's just
an exports field and that implies an es
2019 package and then packages with both
exports and main fields
where maine provides an es5 and common
js fallback for older environments
what does this all mean the bottom line
is that
soon if you don't transpile package
exports
there is a high likelihood that you'll
ship modern code by accident
and maybe shipping modern code is okay
the key is that you define a version of
modern
that strikes the right balance between
js features and browser support
our research has shown that es2017 is a
sweet spot here
since it has 95 percent browser support
offers huge improvements over es5 and is
still really close to what we all think
of as modern
syntax yeah we're not saying that you
should only write es2017
it's much the opposite es2017 is a great
transpile target
transpiling the most recent es 2020
syntax features to es 2017
is generally extremely cost effective
transpiled outputs like this 408 loop
are the kind of thing we're looking for
the overhead incurred here is only
four bytes but maybe you do need to
support internet explorer 11
or opera minis extreme mode thankfully
there's a really solid way to support
older browsers without
impacting newer ones first
generate es2017 bundles for your
application and serve those to modern
browsers using script type module
then generate polyfilled es5 bundles and
serve those
to legacy browsers using script no
module
there's no expensive server setup or
user agent snipping required
and it lines up really nicely with our
es2017 sweet spot
there are two ways to generate these two
sets of javascript files
the first is to compile your application
twice
and the second is to compile your
application for modern and then
transpile the output
with the first technique we run a build
of the application as if we were only
going to support
modern browsers each source module gets
transpiled to es2017
by something like babum or typescript
then code is bundled
then we run a second full build of the
application but this time
with the transpiler configured to
convert modules to es5
and add polyfills the result
is independent sets of javascript
bundles that we can load modern
and legacy browsers the second approach
flips things around a bit
we run a single build to generate es2017
bundles for modern browsers
then we transpile those bundles down to
es5
with polyfills one great advantage of
this approach
is that all code including any
dependencies can be es
2017. since the whole build assumes
modern code
all code can't be modern
it'll all be transpiled when generating
the legacy versions of bundles
now this is all really important because
ie11 is a tax we
and our users don't have to pay
consider the cost as you think about
your site's performance
if you need to support ie11 be careful
not to degrade the experience for the
majority of visitors
in order to get there we hope we've made
the case
for why modern javascript is so
important
we also want to make this as easy as
possible to adopt
so we've published a how-to article that
provides configurations
for popular build tools to get you
started yeah and depending on your setup
this can be as easy as installing a
plugin
if you're curious what kind of impact
turning on modern javascript would have
on your website
today we're launching a tool for that
load the tool enter the url of the page
and it will analyze the javascript
of that page in order to calculate how
much smaller and faster
that page would be if it leveraged
modern code
go check it out let us know what you
think we're also working on something
similar for npm packages
and any feedback for this version helps
make that one better too
thank you and we hope you enjoyed
listening as much as we enjoyed giving
this presentation
thanks for watching
you